hey i'm austin mahone I just dropped my
brand new single Dancing with nobody and
today i'm with BuzzFeed talking about
all of my firsts so here we go first
song I wrote I can't even remember if it
was probably terrible first celebrity
crush I would say first and forever
always really she's the best first kiss
my first kiss was when I was 13 years
old and I was at my crushes birthday
party and we were in her swimming pool
just having fun you know splashing
around and the next thing I know she
pulls me underwater plants on Tommy and
then pushes me back up and I don't know
what happened but it was magical first
celebrity that I met I can't remember
the first celebrity that I ever met but
I can recall the first time that I was
ever really starstruck and I would say
that would be when I met my childhood
hero George Strait in Las Vegas and I
had just turned 21 so it was kind of
like a 21 Vegas party for me my mom was
there she took me to the George Strait
concert and I got to share a shot with
George from his new liquor that he just
came out with so that's definitely a
moment that I will never ever forget and
I definitely embarrassed myself that day
because being a country man myself
you know the right way to greet another
country man is a firm handshake could I
just went for the hug the first time
someone recognized me in public I think
it was probably at Northstar Mall in San
Antonio because when I was just getting
my start me and my boy AC would fill up
our backpacks with flyers that we had
made at home telling people to subscribe
to our YouTube channel so we would just
fill our backpacks up and just go to the
mall and just dump all the Flyers out
like in stores and like at the food
court and so I think that was probably
like the first time someone was like hey
wait maybe that kid that just dropped
this flyer on the ground I know you the
first time you heard someone use the
word my homie I said it first I came up
with it so I was thinking I was like
what should I stand my fans be name
everybody has a fan base and they have a
cool name what am I going to name mine
my home my homey founders came to me and
then my boys he was like my homey that's
genius
and then stuff from their first big date
I never really went on a lot of dates
growing up so I think my first date was
actually
planned and buy a magazine when I was
like 14 15 and they're like oh yeah
you're gonna go on a date with a lucky
fan it gets you know that chance to win
something all right cool we went to some
Italian restaurant and was a great
dinner was a great date and I think that
was my first big date really shout out
Claudia first breakup mMmmm my first
breakup with stuff I sled the country
first CD you ever bought my first album
that I ever bought was a Rascal Flatts
CD called me and my gang and I remember
going to Barnes & Noble to pick it up
and I was like my first time really like
figuring out that they sew music at
Barnes ennoble I thought which is all
books but then I came across a CD Rascal
Flatts I know them I like them so I was
my first CD the first time you realized
you wanted to pursue a music career
after I got my channel started and it
was just going pretty pretty quickly and
I was getting a lot of views a lot of
subscribers I was getting flown out to
my fans like houses just to do like a
birthday party for them or just to hang
out so once like I started really
traveling and like going places with my
music I was like alright this is this is
definitely something like I got it I got
to see how far I can take this so that's
probably around like 14 15 first musical
inspiration I would say my first musical
inspiration would be George Strait who I
mentioned earlier so I grew up in San
Antonio Texas also where George Strait
is from and growing up that's all I
heard in the car and the house on the
street on the radio so he's definitely
my biggest musical inspiration and I
definitely embarrassed myself when I met
him